ladies and gentlemen every motion
picture performer here tonight is a
member of the Screen Actors Guild it's
an honor to present our president mr.
John Gavin who will present the film
editing award with one of his dreamiest
and most gifted constituents mrs.
Katherine Ross
well I tell you what we met a do how
about just a quick thank you and we'll
get on with it and let's get on with it
used again you see how easy it is okay
for the best achievement in film editing
the nominees are cabaret David
bretherton deliverance Tom priestly The
Godfather William Reynolds and Peter's
dinner the hot rock Frank P Keller and
Fred W Berger the Poseidon Adventure
Harold F kress and the winner is using
the opener that Cloris left here the
winner is David Brethren tons of Cabaret
I only wish tonight that my mouth was or
perhaps his talent is my hands so I
could thank you all very much
I see mr. Manoli there she was a mentor
of mine it's Joel Grey Bob Fosse I met
her illusion I thank you all especially
the members of the Academy promoting
voting me this is really great honor I
appreciate it thank you